ليس الاتهام الاول الذي يواجههم محمد
رمضان
باستفزاز جمهوره لكن هذه المره كان الامر
اكثر جدلا من اي مره سابقه فمع صوره نشرها
النجمه المصري وطبعا شاهد هالجميع في
طائره الخاصه بجانب رزم من الدولارات اصبح
رمضان قبل ايام حديث مواقع التواصل ووسائل
الاعلام ايضا الامر تجاوز تهمه الاستفزاز
الطبيب المصري الشهير جمال شعبان طالب
رمضان بان يدفع من هذه المبالغ جزءا لاجل
الفقراء المرضى تعليق الطبيب وجد اذنا
صاغيا من رمضان الذي اجتمع بالطبيب ووعده
بدعم المرضى والعمل الخيري ليظهر سويا
بصوره واحده كل هذا لم ينفع رمضان الذي
تعرض للسخريه كبيره من الفنان خالد سرحان
ليرد رمضان بسخريه مماثله
[موسيقى]
طيب الدكتور خلينا نبدا لو حبذا لو تضعنا
في صوره تفاصيل الاحداث اللي جرت والحديث
اللي جرى بينك وما بين الفنان محمد رمضان
يعني هو قبل الحديث انا كنت دايما برضو
بنتقد هذا الاسلوب بتاعه بس اسلوبي يعني
ما كانش يعني بيتخطى حدود اللياقه يعني
انا اهتم جدا ان انت لما تواجه نقد
الانسان
تواجهه باسلوب جميل غير الاسلوب الحادي
اللي بيظهر احيانا على السوشيال ميديا
والاستقطاب الحادي اللي بيظهر في السوشيال
ميديا المره دي انا قلت طيب احاول اديله
بقى حل فقولت له انا شايف ان انت وانت
متصور مع الدولارات يعني مش باصص لها يعني
شكلها كده مش محتاج لها فانا عندي حالات
بتعاني من اختلال كهربائي القلب حالات
خطيره
وكانوا منزلين على صفحتي من يومين شاب
عنده 18 سنه عنده خطر التوقف القلب
المفاجئ ومحتاج جهاز كهربيه تمنه بيتجاوز
200 الف واحيانا بيصل ال 300 الف جنيه
مصري
فقال لي طيب حاول تقول لي اسماء ومستشفيات
محتاجه وبعت لي رقمك على الخاص بعثت له
الرقم فاتصل بيا تاني يوم الصبح وبعد كده
اتفقنا واتقابلنا بالليل واظهر استعداده
للمشاركه في علاج الحالات وطلبنا اول حاله
مصريه بسيطه من الصعيد ما كانتش مصدقه ان
هو بيكلمها وانا كنت معه
وان شاء الله يتم تركيب هذا الجهاز هيتكفل
هو بكل النفقات بتاعته هل ستكون مساعده
الفنان محمد رمضان هي مساعده واحده ام
عمليه مستمره وبالتالي هو يعني من كان
يشاهد يقول والله بلديه اموال وبالدولارات
اذا هي تعطيك مبلغ كبير في اذا حولتها الى
الجنيه المصري هل سيكون هذا عمليه مستمره
ولا هي مره واحده وخلاص شو اعلامي كما
يقال لا ايه اعلامي خالص الوعد قال انه في
كل هذه الحالات بل هو بيفكر وانا اقترحت
عليه يعمل مؤسسه يعني تبقى مشهره لدعم هذه
الحالات بحيث يبقى بطريقه مؤسسيه بدل ما
تبقى حالات كده عابره يبقى في نشاط مؤسسي
جمعيه خيريه تتبني هذه الحالات الخطيره
اللي مش قادره وهو قال لي ان امه هي اللي
بتوجهه في القصه دي ان هو بيودي للقصر
العيني ويودي لابو الريش وبيشتري حضانات
وحاجات ما بيحبش يعلن يعني الدكتور جمال
ما تكلمت معه انه ليه بيعمل هذه الحركه
ليه بيحط الفلوس جنبه على الطياره اكيد
هذا سؤال بديهي وقالي والله العظيم انا لا
اقصد استفزاز الناس لاننا رجل من البسطاء
وطلعت من البسطاء
فيها ناس كثير من البسطاء دي رسائل بيقول
دي رسائل بواجهها لناس معينين لكن مش
متسارع المصري
هي بتتفهم اه اه
[موسيقى]